on parle beaucoup des restaurants on
parle beaucoup de tout ça et c'est très
bien mais la culture c'est la nourriture
la culture faut pas l'oublier
[Musique]
c'est toujours un moment un peu magique
alors c'est peut-être lié à l'enfance
s'est faite il ya ça c'est peut-être au
plaisir d'aller au cinéma où c'était une
joie il sortit un moment à part donc
j'ai toujours ça au moment où je rends
douche pousse la porte de la salle je
vois tous ces fauteuils de quelques
personnes assises ou beaucoup voilà
c'est toujours un bonheur ce western
spaghetti qui s'appelle mon nom est
personne
je me souviens du cinéma qui est sur la
plage de dunkerque est un système qui
n'existe plus cinéma du casino
je suis avec mon cousin et des copains à
lui qui sont plus grands que moi je suis
petit et je me souviens de ce film ce
western incroyable avec henry fonda ya
henry fonda dedans et ya terrance il
avec une musique dingue le thème de mon
nom est personne vous connaissez tous
toulon le connais tu sais plus si tu es
folle quoi que tu n'as pas de n'importe
qui je me souviens de mon émerveillement
quand j'ai vu les aventuriers de l'arche
perdue
j'étais fou quoi j'étais comme un fou en
sortant chaque scène chaque fois ça
succéder il se trouve et qui tout était
parfait et cette fin incroyable avec
l'entrepôt oui kim est l'arche
d'alliance comme ça dans cet entrepôt
est lancé et ça m'avait beaucoup
impressionné
et voilà j'étais sorti avec une énergie
folle de de ce film et je dis c'est
possible de faire des films comme ça
quel génie snec donc je viens d'arriver
à paris et je vais au cinéma sur les
champagnes en salle sur les champs et il
passait c'est arrivé près de chez vous
qui avait dû être présenté déjà calmé
moi moche et pas trop ce que c'était
évidemment je connaissais pas benoît
poelvoorde je connaissais rien mais
c'est elle affiche cette affiche avec
cet homme qui tire là ça m'avait plu et
ça commence avec tes vannes très très
drôle où par exemple pour les nains
c'est une façon points c'est beaucoup
plus lourd et je commence à
éclaté de rire se trouve ça
extraordinaire c'est c'est un humour qui
me plaît tellement et c'est sur alice
pourquoi parce que j'ai jamais vécu ça
le nombre de gens qui quittaient la
salle et qui quittait la salle de
manière bruyante en voulant vraiment
revendiquer leur rejet c'est
inadmissible c'est pas possible de faire
des films pareils je me dis qu'est-ce
qui est est ce que ce film provoque et
moi évidemment c'est une référence et un
c'est une référence de comédie c'est un
très très grand film puis c'est là où on
a découvert benoît et le génie le génie
de ses lecteurs c'est star wars c'est le
premier la guerre des étoiles le premier
voilà je n'ai pas vu sur grand écran
donc 77 j'avais 10 ans et je suis passé
à côté
c'est marrant hein mes copains y aller
moi je sais pas pourquoi c'est bizarre
la vie un je ne sais pas pourquoi je
n'avais pas envie donc j'ai vu la guerre
des étoiles bien bien après donc je
regrette de ne pas avoir eu cette
émotion de la guerre des étoiles et de
ce fameux générique avec la musique et
le générique écrit la quitte ce défi bah
j'aime beaucoup aller au cinéma en fin
de matinée vers 11 heures j'adore pour
déjà parce que parce que les gamins
mondain c'est bien sûr le principe
et puis je ne sais pas ça commence ma
journée ça commencera journée c'est le
mec qui s'élève à 10 heures c'est la
grosse feignasse
non j'aime bien ça parce qu'après je
peux penser au film toute la journée ça
me plaît depuis
après je sors c'est l'heure du déjeuner
passé simple enfin c'est comme tout bon
enfant comme tout le monde c'est au
milieu pas trop loin pas trop prêt
classique mais voilà ça me plaît mais
des fois je suis étonnée je vais au
cinéma je rentre dans la salle je vois
des gens assis dans le coin complètement
genre au deuxième rang devant dans le
coin à droite je me dis mais en fait
pourquoi darnauzan en ça dépend j'ai
souvent pas grand chose à dire après oui
c'est vrai il me faut un petit peu de
temps j'aime bien rester un peu dans le
film donc non je suis plus alors auto
digestion christopher nolan le prochain
je sais pas quand il sort avec les
problèmes de confinement des salles
fermées
malheureusement ce que ça va bouger un
peu ça parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
restaurants parle beaucoup de tout ça et
c'est très bien mais la culture c'est la
nourriture la culture faut pas l'oublier
et je trouve que là on n'en parle pas
assez
et quand je dis cinéma je pense au
spectacle en général évidemment et à
tous les gens qui travaillent les gens
d'entretien qui nettoie qui vont
nettoyer les salles les les caissières
de caissier dans les cinémas tout le
personnel tous les gens qui travaillent
si travail qui aiment leur métier
les techniciens ben voilà tous ces gens
là ils ont envie de travailler
ils ont besoin de travailler et on peut
pas leur couper le rôle qui travaille
comme ça il faut avec des conditions
bien sûr de sanitaires avec tout ce
qu'il faut faire tout ce qu'on fait
d'ailleurs part je vois pas pourquoi ça
ne peut pas être appliquée au cinéma